as long as the meetings take that is how
long I'll be here I was here I was in
Athens for the last two weeks and now
we're here and we will like the leaders
see it to the bitter end I think you
have to remember if you look at
Tuesday's eurozone summit and tusks
comments and yonkers comments and all of
that
they'd set this as a deadline and guess
what
whatever deadline this was meant to be
it's not and I think what we're seeing
here is credibility of everybody on the
table you can't say to people sunday is
the day of decision and when sunday
comes round will it will give it a bit
longer and that's what they've done
that's what's gonna happen tonight
that's what's gonna happen tonight
they're gonna kick this down the road
and I pity and wonder what actually
happens in Greece it's very difficult
the fatigue euro fatigue is huge I'm
look I'm a business journalist I eat
drink and sleep this stuff but my
editors are my producers on the various
programmes their eyes roll and they
start to think oh no no and particularly
when you say here's another deadline oh
nope this is really the deadline I
promise you this is the deadline know
this and it goes on yeah you get used to
it
you just get you said but I have a
problem and the problem is I'm rather
loud that I broadcast and we're all
quite close to each other and I can see
the other journalists or the reporters
on either side of me thinking oh god I'm
standing next to quest you know and I
try and keep it down and I don't
genuinely wish to broadcast with every
Network just by shouting but it's not
easy